[Musique]
au réveil en pleine forme il tient donc
ses épaules mais je ne sois pas une
graine de voyous insiste ressemble ça
serait bien en faire un repère
[Musique]
il fera ce qu'il voudra
si la vie de bras qui liera bras qui
était tir à maîtriser ok ça change quoi
que tu vois un mec quatre ans deux ans
de plus que trois juges munger et bien
je pense que ça permette des rapports
privilégiés et inviolable
[Musique]
serait pas intello sur les bords
tu as tant qu'obstacle je sais pas
peut-être pas je te disais je vais vous
pouvez me serrer la main je l'aï sacré
quoi d'avoir un enfant avec l'arrière
nièce du général von paulus du jeu
assure m
si ce n est l héroïne de melody nelson
est ce que moi je suis sam en italie
boeing deux hommes de race les yeux gris
demeurer en double et alors ce que je
baissais tubize c'est lorsque je faisais
ça bouge clauses dites vous connaissez
le parfum soleil vert tient le français
ça serait de nabokov mais je suis
impliqué janus con
mais oui tu ça monte quelque part
tu crois qu'on va rester longtemps sans
corde raide
mathématiquement parlant
où
je casse et même people j'espère pour
toi
viendra un jour dans ce sens là
sais tu aimes c'est mathématique at-il
dit pas si élémentaire mon cher tu crois
que tu seras avec qui sinon s'étaient
pas rencontrés
je pense que surpris
parmi eux m
[Musique]
on n'a qu'un des hackers ça suffit une
perse
on
pas rester assis toi tu auras plus le
dernier de la dernière nuit ma p'tite
cocotte minute
bon eh toi tu ferais quoi bon la région
s'étaient pas rencontrés je sais pas du
tout je sais pas si sûr encore lave et à
plein de choses que j'aime ça aurait eu
un destin complètement différente et
c'est pas
de marquer au fer rouge là hélas
indélébile
qu'est ce qui te lèves le plus chez moi
un des sautes d'humeur de
l'électrocardiogramme tu peux parler je
vais pas et pire que moi
je t'ai déjà cassaigne pompe
tu te rappelles tu as le sont 10
connaissent pas mais moi je suis un
lâche après
moi je prends l'écoutons
ah ouais jeu du couteau planté dans le
haut valais chantage
tu ferais quoi ces sites éviter
bref si tu me quittes et ben je dis à m
quote tu serais pas la première et que
tu souhaites tu as ta dernière
c'est pas mal parce que toutes les
pinces accroché au radiateur
comment
il ya fait à pied du bouge pas de l'est
cette affiche est content chaîne s'est
tiré avec trio no comments d'accord
touche pas à ce que tu as tout à dire ma
vie hertz
c'est vrai qu'au début des années 60
quand tu t'es marié avec une princesse
qualité le garçon
on peut partager en deux
ben eager avec titi n'est pas resté plus
ou ligue 1 parce que je l ai pu te
situes tu es marié sait que c'est que
c'est que régime en compte à partir du
moment où tu t'es marié que ça commence
à décoller pour ça que tous les deux on
est à l'école
moi non plus moi c'est pas si
la pendre les femmes pour ce qu'elle ne
chante pas elle et c'est parce qu'elle
respecte ça
pour test le 7
plus tu sais pas
[Musique]
je te prends toi parce que tu n'es pas
n'est ce pas aussi parce que tu prennes
baby dee les équipes red bull va
commencer déjà très très bien ouais il
aurait pu la et du tout elana penche pas
bon ça déchirait prend ça très bien quoi
oui moi je crois qu est ce qui définit
son produit c'est d'arrêter de là
qu'est ce qu'il fait y conte de fées
cigarettes et comptines en cash comme on
le sait il va bien ça va ça dit avec lui
j'ai découvert ce que j'avais pas connu
c'est vrai c'est vrai parce que j'essaye
de lui apporter comme j'ai eu une
enfance un peu
perturbée dans son second geneco ni
connu mon père ni vraiment ma mère et je
suis resté 13 assistance publique et
c'est vrai que bon avec lui je retrouve
tout ce que j'ai prévu de lâcher ou des
bêtises
c'est vrai qu'un jour annuelles ont
offert un martinet c'est vrai j'avais
fait un cadeau chien il y avait un chien
fin c'était mon copain c'est son copain
j'avais et il avait fait un martinet
pour le chien est un roman
c'est un beau cadeau au moins j'avais eu
un cadeau ce moment de ton père tu as
retrouvé qu'en montarges est né retrouvé
quand j'avais 15 ans par hasard j'ai
peur je lis jamais en fait j'ai géré la
possibilité de darryl voir mais j'ai pas
voulu je me suis dit 13 ans en lui et en
plus il est fou oui ça l'est
généralement et je crois qu'il n'a pas
supportée rejet ouais quand ils verront
en france
en quatre mois ouais c'est le fils du
général von paulus pas du maréchal quoi
finir ses passes 8 a perdu stalingrad et
d'amères émanèrent dash et c'est madame
x man 10
descendant d'une famille aristocrate
chinoise de pékin et comment est passé
il
sa famille s'est fait massacrer
eddie lui a exorcisé mais ressenti
manger tout pardonner c'est vrai tapis
de ressentiment maintenant on entre
contre les gens ça dépend qui enfin tout
ce qui concerne mon enfance moi je n'ai
aucune rancoeur face aux super quelqu'un
de compliqué je suis en général une
bonne forme et est vraiment c'est vrai
que les lieux n'a été a enfin oublier
certaines choses et pas en vouloir à
pleuvoir à ces choses là
quant à farid ben bella c'est un disque
externe ou vivendi de chine lors d'un
tour des pathologistes le reste écrit
par gainsbourg enuite chine
la personne qui a écrit mme une chine
qui aimante rien
a voulu que si quelqu'un vous prenez la
chanson que tous les trois à une petite
soeur à dulles
bon je t'ai beaucoup et donc serge
girard et à serge rien une ration de 33
tours parce qu'il a tout fait ces
paroles si j'avais du mal pour toi t'as
fait ça je crois qu'il est assez sur
mesure il pige quantique c'est vraiment
un très beau cadeau
[Musique]
rencontre la savane je suis content
pour faire un petit questionnaire de
proust et pas je prête je suis prête à
tout
[Musique]
quel serait pas le compte de la lisière
par exemple eh bien ça serait de boire
de l'eau chaude parce que j'ai pas les
moyens de me payer un sachet de thé ah
oui pôle asiatique c'est terrible nature
c'est effrayant effrayant et pourtant ça
existe j'aimerais vivre
[Musique]
je le vois je pense que j'aimerais
retourner en chine
[Musique]
finir mes jours en chine les
montalbanais comment ça pulse en chine
c'est quoi ton idéal de bonheur
terrestre
[Musique]
idéal de bonheur terrestre c'est haddad
a sûrement dit et non et pour quelle
faute à tu le plus la juge
[Musique]
pour
des personnes qui
qui s'appuie à mentir ouais
parce que généralement personnes qui
savent pas mentir
elles savent bien avouer aussi assez
facilement
or c'est
c'est assez vite pardon est monté à
glasgow
[Musique]
pas longtemps
comment tu voudrais mourir
[Musique]
j'espère mourir
enfin 70 et du gaz mais non c'est pas du
genre à part en compagnie accueille
maintenant aux bambins
il faut
bon bon bon soir donc il parlait bonsoir
qui est pas dernier du vendée globe
contre 1 - selon lui par romane
bohringer kamel axelle laffont voilà les
plus en plus de filles sur ce plateau ça
devient très sympa alors serge
gainsbourg a eu trois baies dans sa vie
bardot birkin et bambou en ce qui vous
concerne celui qui a inventé le b
puisque c'est un surnom qui vous qui
vous a donné votre vrai nom c'est
caroline elisabeth von paulus et quand
vous rencontrez serge vous rencontrer
serge et vous arrivez d'aller fumer de
l'opium chez un vieux chinois vous dites
tiré sur le bon bout ça s'appelle les
noms qui vous dit où tu vas je vais
tirer sur le bon bout donc si vous
appelez bombe howell plus simple votre
père était légionnaire les généralement
qui a rencontré votre mère au vietnam
votre mère c'est madame fomen 10 qui
descend d'une famille aristocrate de
pékin massacrés par mao et donc ils
immigrent votre perle légionnaires
allemand et votre mère descendante de
cette famille aristocrate immigrants
france mais se séparent assez rapidement
très rapidement après leur arrivée en
france
votre mère se retrouve dans un camp de
réfugiés vietnamiens dans le lot ça vous
êtes né à villeneuve sur lot
voilà ces deux immeubles sur lot un
scoop mesdames messieurs et donc votre
mère se retrouve avec six enfants à
élever
vous vous retrouvez la dass vous dès
l'âge de 6 mois à 6 mois jusqu'à 13 ans
alors évidemment vous retrouver dans une
famille ça arrive aux autres dans une
famille pas très pas très cool comme
dans toutes les familles c'est un peu
cause elle quoi en gros vous êtes une
fois j'ai eu le même cadeau que le chien
pour noël absolument
martinez et un bout de bois avec des
lanières chloé et le chien avait
exactement la même chose en 13 ans j'ai
ce cadeau c'est ce qui est déjà pas mal
pour rester bien vous êtes assez fleet
et quand vous êtes petit vous essayez
d'ouvrir les vannes à 9 ans la vie vous
intéressait déjà plus à cet âge-là je
pensais que je m'étais gouré de monde je
savais pas ce que je suis face à serge
avait le même problème
vous demandez vous aviez atterré quoi
donc effectivement c'est ça qui vous a
amené plus tard vers l'avant la drogue
vous dites je ne voulais pas vivre
jusqu'à 30 ans en fait vous avez une
ligne de vie qui fait le tour du poignet
non vous n'êtes pas à wels à je suis mal
barré maintenant vous avez un ancêtre
qu'avec jusqu'à s'entend donc sans un
témoin le piano que ça comme ça le
sursis va être long on a donc tenait
encore pour un moment là voilà pour lui
ouais il faut vous faire une raison
alors effectivement à l'âge de 13 ans
l'idée de la mort est toujours assez
présente chez vous et vous allez vous
défoncer quoi jour en sortant du lycée
vous allez chez eux chez un dealer en
fait du baby sitting groupe l'idée fixe
non oui je volais des mobylettes enfin
je serai beaucoup de choses
à l'époque j'étais active wheel personne
ne m'a amené à la drogue j'y suis allé
tout seul au moins vous avez le mérite
d'accuser personne d'autre je pense
qu'on est assez grand et on sait ce
qu'on fait
c'est tellement facile de mettre la
faute sur quelqu'un d'autre alors que
non alors quand vous rencontrez serge
gainsbourg et 19 ans vous traîner un peu
c'est là qu'on s'est connus vous traînez
impec l'époque avant donc vous traîner
un peu avec l'époque du palace et c'est
eux qui vous ont fait découvrir la
musique de gainsbourg parce que vous
étiez pas branché du tout et vous
flashez sur l'homme à la tête de chou
que vous préférez à melody nelson
un mois c'est ce qu'il a fait de mieux à
on y joue lyrics toute musique tout
enfin tout un concept album comme ça
c'est c'est parfait c'est la perfection
alors vous le rencontrer à l'elysée
matignon en droit aujourd'hui disparu et
alors
il ya un type qui vient vous dire
monsieur gainsbourg ordonne que vous
alliez à sa table vous dites quoi
ce vieux con qu'il aille se faire [ __ ]
quoi bah oui des ordres qui voulez vous
donner des ordres
déjà ils arrivent vers vous il vous dit
le vieux con il vient à ta table espèce
de boudin c'était sympa comme entrée en
matière le vieux con vraiment trop
alors effectivement à l'époque il était
assez malheureux parce que jane venait
de le quitter il était blessé chercher
quelqu'un qui comprenne
on croyait plan qu il voulait quelqu'un
qu'ils comprennent sans avoir besoin de
parler ce qui se comprend assez bien
toujours mieux les couples on n'est pas
obligé de parler des paysages ya tic
sont très fortes l'admr et c'est vrai à
l'époque si vous n'aviez pas été aussi
défoncé est-ce que vous l'auriez
supporter dans l'état où ils étaient
parce que vous c'est pas gainsbourg j'ai
connu ce comme gainsbarre
oui mais je me souviens qu'à 14 ans sur
le voyais à la télé je me disais si je
devais enfin si je voulais un papa je
voudrais pas comme lui
et j'ai été exaucé au delà des
espérances
et c'est drôle parce que les bus est
tombé sur des lettres et où il voit mon
petit papa de ce gta capable d'écrire
serge donc dans mais lâche marc est
toujours mon petit papa et oies on a le
même papa et c'est vrai que buvaient et
moi je prenais des substances qui
m'aidait à supporter l'insupportable je
ne m'en vante pas mais je l'assumé
de toute façon lui au courant de tour
donc il ya aucun problème et c'est vrai
que ça peut-être facilité certaines
choses qui et qui était assez lourde à
porter alors comme il pleurait les x
games beau et malraux il pleurait mais
quand vous approchiez lui que vous lui
disiez ne pleure pas il n'inquiète pas
c'est les larmes de crocodile
étaient manipulateurs été acteur très
wimbée puis en même temps c'était
sincère puis en même temps il avait un
recul sur lui même en se disant bon
allez faut pas l'inquiéter là c'est vrai
il se trouvait moche tout le monde le
sait c'est vrai qu'à un moment et vous
laisse crever un oeil pour qu'on
l'appelle serge le borgne et pour dire
comme ça au moins on saura pourquoi ces
pages suivantes
donc là je suis mal je voulais justifier
sa sale gueule c'est vrai ça je savais
pas et un jour il vous demande d'arrêter
la dope vraiment quoi décrocher
parce que il voulait avoir un enfant
vous avez déjà eu un avant vous aviez
perdu voilà et là vous êtes dit
franchement même pas que ces convois et
c'est sa personne sont été aperçus que
nous étions au sein de même pas vous est
donc là vous vous dites je vais arrêter
et puis on va faire le faire proprement
comme celle à des camps même temps avant
lui deux ans aurait deux en avant
effectivement vous avant quand vous
voyez des femmes enceintes ça vous ça
vous choqué parce que vous disiez il ya
tellement de malheureux sur la terre
dieu sait si vous aviez été
malheureusement votre vie mais il ya
tellement de malheureux sur la terre
c'est pas la peine d'en faire un de plus
prenez les convives des femmes ans et
nous avions envie de réécouter dans le
ventre j'étais très violent quand j'ai
vu ma soeur aînée en ceintes c'était je
comprenais pas et je me disais mais
pourquoi ils font des conclusions de
l'enquêté un clin qui sont malheureux
compact hareng et qui demande qu'une
chose d'être adoptés un peu l'amour est
dans une grossesse difficile en plus
donc mal gré mal gré la décrochent une
partie sous perfusion dans la cause des
contractions ria six mois les lieux vous
des sortira six mois petit consenti à
vis moi est quelque chose mais mois et
trois semaines
c'est ça alors serge n'ont plus supporté
pas trop les femmes enceintes ça oui
c'est vrai tu reviens avec le paquet
cadeau cadeaux puis est ce qui a été
très étonnant c'est qu'il a été odieux
avec moi tant que ça se voyait pas et
dès que j'ai commencé à avoir un petit
autres il a été d'un amour ça reste est
de la folie c'était tout le contraire de
ce qu'ils m'avaient dit et moi j'étais
prête à partir à lui ramener des cadeaux
n'avait pas de problème est la non il
n'essaie plus partir alors lui voulait
une fille on sait pas pourquoi parce
qu'il en avait déjà eu
- charlotte puis ses enfants d'un prêt
d'un premier mariage et voulait une
fille une petite chinoise et donc il est
le garçon va pas été très content de lui
évidemment comme je l'aï déjà dit c'est
lui qui m'a donné envie de faire des
enfants fait trois de plus alors quand
l'enfant né la presse parce qu'ils
étaient bons gars pour les médias
c'était son truc donc que vous êtes en
page 3 de france soir deux d'entre eux
en première page
et parce que la presse voulait
absolument attendait un enfant
bizarre quoi puisque vous étiez jack lui
l'était alcoolo penser différemment
donc quand tu vois que c'est un bébé
normal et tout mettre en troisième page
de françois roux to better
il a été consterné en disant mais [ __ ]
quand il ya des bonnes nouvelles sont
pas contents on se retrouve en troisième
page est effréné accroc en aurait eu là
une voilà c'est ça mais c'est vrai
qu'ils manipulaient beaucoup les médias
par exemple la barbe de trois jours
c'était toujours un truc était un petit
peu entre très dandy parce que rétais
c'est beaucoup de boulot
ouais d'avoir une barbe de trois jours
et savoir quel jour il faut se raser et
pas quel jour et c'était très bon direct
et l'histoire des billets de 500 francs
qu'il est brûlé à 7 sur 7 il l'avait il
avait réfléchi s'était pas ce contenu
deux semaines avant et c'est justement
des caisses qui pouvait faire ils me
demandaient tu crois que je peux le
faire et si je vais en taule tu viendras
me voir tu m'apportes rade et orange et
j'ai été bien si donc il savait tout ça
oui c'est vrai qu'il a pleuré quand il
n'a pas eu la une de match parce qu'il
pleurait toujours pour voir la une de
match
vous n'avez jamais eu un jour il vous
dit
je lui les gens de match au téléphone si
tu lui si tu te montres sur la une avec
le bébé et nous la donne vous vouliez le
protéger ce bébé et malgré tout vous
l'avez fait la une de match ce qui est
très attendrissant oui quelque part de
jouer avec eux puis en même temps il
comprenait pas qu'il y avait pas un
retour immédiat quoi parce que lui il
stone est complètement et c'était très
très calculée defour bien sûr mais c'est
vrai qu'avec le talent qu'il avait la
une de match c'est pas grand chose par
rapport à tous alors quand il allait la
télé un peu pété un peu bourré comme ça
vous langue olivier comment j'étais en
sortant de l'émission à vous comme vous
étiez vous l'aimiez lui disais mais
terrible oui mais ils me disent est une
[ __ ] me démolir le moral et tous et à
la fin j'ai pas quoi faire donc pas ce
cas précités la gueule pendant une
semaine les terrassements sympa et donc
après je les enregistre et qui se voit
pas voulu montrer les cassettes vidéo
est ce que je pouvais pas dire que
c'était bien qu il était complètement
et puis c'était gainsbarre et puis il
fallait qu'il en finisse avec ça qu'ils
sont la page donc je voulais qu'il soit
et qui les reculs et là il a été choqué
et là tu arrivé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
ici
la séance d'enregistrement ça a été
terrible il vous faut et en plus le
retour en studio j'avais les paroles
juste au moment même et je me suis mis
quand je vais faire il m'a insulté
j'étais à côté de la plaque et tout on a
dû faire sortir du studio
ah oui oui parce que ça laisse car
mineure mécontent parce qu'il a écrit
l'élu enfant de l'amour quoi ça c'était
soirée et après il est revenu et tout
s'est bien passé
vous avez dit un truc pas je sais pas si
c'est très beau mais en tous les cas
c'est très touchant
vous êtes donc beaucoup souffert comme
on l'a vu pendant votre pendant votre
enfance et vous dites lui a exorcisé
mais ressentiment et j'ai pardonné
certains se faisait pardonner au reste
du monde pour qu'ils vous aviez envers
qui vous aviez une vraie violence ont
passé j'avais peu de rancoeur quand j'ai
trait continu avec le monde et lui lundi
mais oui j'ai sauvé une vie en donnant
la vie voilà alors lui voulait mourir en
dormant un gainsbourg c'était son rêve
il avait peur de la mort il disait
toujours le mieux c'est que les dieux
l'ont exaucé il est mort en dormant
alors après sa mort évidemment vous vous
c'est difficile pour vous vous avez
manqué de retomber dans la came à ce
moment là non j'ai été blessée parce que
les médias en nous on est complètement
son militaire est allé se sait c'est que
j'ai pas voulu jouer le jeu non plus
donc je suis responsable de ça mais
c'est vrai que lui est tombé sur
certains livres et il m'a dit mais si
toi tu es une erreur sur la deuxième
parce que apparemment papa il a aimé que
jen et jets d'huile qui croit pas ça
qu'est ce que tu fous là
donc là vous avez été malade une espèce
de maladie un peu psy cosmétiques vous
êtes devenu has et parano et et c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de critiques à ce
moment là on vous reprocher d'en avoir
voulu combler de serge d'être doublés de
serre je sais bien
on sait bien sûr renoncer à tous je sais
bien mais à l'époque je dis les gens
vous en vous en reprocher ça on m'a
sorti pire que ça ouais vous n'avez rien
fait non plus pour rester dans le milieu
je dirai pas ce qu'un jour vous êtes
invité à dîner par françoise hardy et
jacques dutronc qui sont le la marraine
et le parrain de lulu et vous y allez
pas mais sans prévenir quoi si vous
n'êtes pas très social
bon bon c'est vrai mais j'avais des
raisons très personnelles pour ne plus y
aller on est d'accord
ah oui c'est pas juste pour payer avec
quoi et à partir de là vous reprenez
confiance c'est à dire que comme
d'habitude quand on touche le fond
remonte à près au bout d'un moment vous
reprenez conscience et vous décidez
d'être une super maman
là vous décidez selon le désir de serge
de lui faire apprendre les échecs parce
que serge étant d'origine faire jeu m'a
fait confiance et il m'a toujours dit
que je serai une bonne moment sais pas
si c'est une bonne maman mais j'essaie
de faire de mon mieux et puis par paul
lemay le évidemment passer en premier
vous l'avez fait à prendre les échecs le
piano il a fait combien d'années de il
vient de passer son examen de moyens de
après cdf supérieur et d'affinités
contre voilà c'est bien nous déjà vous
avez rempli la mission mission de mamans
des chats c'était dur parce que l'école
est beau c'est pas trop la vraie école
est la petite-fille grosse attention si
on est déjà reese vous écouter ensemble
des chansons de gainsbourg tous les deux
non c'est très on est très pudique elle
le fait de son côté à part une fois on
était en inde et c'était il ya trois ans
et je crois qu'il avait 13 ans né il ya
deux ans donc il était en train
d'écouter de lire c'était la première
fois je le voyais d'élire les enfin les
lyrics de son père et d'un seul coup il
pose des écouteurs mdina temps maman
papa c'est un génie il rend malaisée qui
veut dire que oui alors on parlait
d'argent tout à l'heure lui va hériter
quand il aura 18 ans d'un quart des
droits d'auteur puisque quatre enfants
qui ont droit ça donc un quart des
droits d'auteur serge l'a pas fait de
testament donc vous finalement vous avez
ce que vous donnez mais l'administrateur
travaillez pas vous avez vous été signé
son avènement vous finalement vous avez
ce que ce qui vous est versé par
l'administrateur ses terres familiales
par mois a finalement c'est pour élever
l'enfant et
pour tous pour l'éducation de l'enfant
pour les pauvres vous n'êtes pas peur
quand on va avoir 18 ans qui va voir
tout ce pognon qui pète un peu les
plombs le plus là ce que je l'emmène
chez l'habitant en asie en afrique et il
voit une autre réalité
il a réagi comment la commémoration de
la mort de son père
ben là c'est pas terrible je crois qui
allait retomber et et c'était comme si
son père était mort la veille le court
voyage de comprendre à 15 ans 15 ans
voilà donc ce qui ce qui comprenait pas
à vendre assure koussa lue il est tombé
sur la tête quoi
interview dernier coup en ébauche
baldinger on ne bouge pas pendant le
signal
bien vous avez un peu romane super sage
vous êtes très sage mais bon non mais
quand ma fille est pas là c'est plus
simple de pas bouger parce qu'il il
entraîne les autres en fait c'est comme
à l'école tu as des mecs qui entraîne
les autres
dernier coup dur tu le connais ouais
c'est quand serge est parti dans les
coups de bol c'est quand j'allais du
génie dernier coup de tête on se porte
d'ailleurs son nom d'asile
oui ah oui c'est vrai importante au
vietnam ou pas pour toujours quand même
moi je vais tuer partir dans les baie
d'halong avec l' aventure chez
l'habitant se remet ça dans les coups de
coeur aulas quel courant dans les coups
de poing sur les murs ah ouais ah oui
c'est à ce point là on n'a pas vu huit
jamais le maître découvre ça m'est
arrivé je lui ai dit si tu continues à
l'école comme ça c'est coup de boule
maintenant aulas c'est pas un coup de
poing ses coups de boule dernier coup de
foudre
c'est un dernier coup de gueule et coups
de fil mais lui l'année coûte place mais
les derniers coups de blues
on dernier comme nous c'était très
récemment et là c'est en train de
continuer un petit coup de blues
dernier coup de rein couvent a laissé
cependant mais c'est vrai nom mais c'est
mais je sais mais vous n'avez pas la
remplacer
non heureusement pc sais pas quoi c'est
mon coeur et puis si mon coeur me dit
rien donné mais qui voudra quand même
oui mais c'est pas mon problème
ou toujours une somme aux non pas du
tout je suis loin d'être une simple ça
c'est clair
mais bon je vous dis ce qui se passe
bien
[Musique]